well joining me now live from pretoria
is kombuchu and savanni
a minister in the presidency thank you
very much indeed for joining us cindy
tell us first of all just
how widespread is the violence from your
perspective and and how concerned are
you
a good evening to you and thank you for
having us the violence is
mostly in two provinces which is the
province of haoteng
and the province of kazaden we are
indeed concerned about the violence
because what it is doing is threatening
not only lives but livelihoods
the looting and the hooliganism they are
they are literally pillaging the
distribution centers of retail companies
their threat they are demolishing or
bringing up malls
and that is a serious concern for us and
in that regard
is the reason the president of the
republic deployed the south african
defense force to strengthen the work of
the police
so do you simply regard it as a law and
order issue are aren't there more
fundamental causes that
really need to be addressed
it is too prone there is serious
elements of criminality
on on the on the surface of it it's it's
that is outright clear
because if it were normal protest south
africans we are used to protesting
most of us who come from the governing
party we know how to make the country
ungovernable by protesting
they will be matching there will be
t-shirts there will be placards but
none of that is taking place this is
pure criminality people are
simply looting but the fundamental issue
in this is
in this in this area is the
socio-economic
challenges of our country my especially
youth unemployment
that is in the country which is very
high but general unemployment
and this is the lockdowns that have been
necessitated
by trying to prevent the spread of covet
19 and to manage their covenanting
because unlike the uk when you have
access to vaccines
and you have vaccinated two-thirds of
your population
we don't have access to those vaccines
we have only managed to vaccinate
five percent of our population so our
only measure that is at our disposal
is the the lockdowns that ensures that
people do not go to work
but most companies are not operating and
most people are losing jobs and with
that
you increase unemployment and we've
always acknowledged and the president of
the republic has acknowledged that
unemployment and more especially youth
unemployment
is at a time it's a it's a ticking bomb
that's going to explode
and when you just get a single spark
it's easy for that to explode
and we have been working consistently
and coherently to deal with
youth unemployment not only through
creating jobs
because it's also to guide our people to
be entrepreneurial
and support them in starting their own
businesses and creating markets for
their products and services it's an
important point you make about
vaccines and the effect then the
knock-on effect on
on lockdowns and and the economy would
you like to see
you we remember the g7 summit those rich
nations
meeting in the uk last month would you
like to see the
follow through on that promise to get
hundreds of millions indeed billions of
doses to
countries like your own has anything
come through yet
what i can say is that what is what is
said to be coming through is not
sufficient enough for
the south africa but also for the
continent of africa in its totality
if you if like i've just indicated the
percentages were vaccinated and we are
amongst the leading nations in africa to
have reached that numbers in vaccination
and you should recall that south africa
has always been a magnet
like any other country that is better
developed that
if south africa is developed and
prosperous or if we're vaccinating
other our sisters and brothers within
the neighboring countries
will have to come through to south
africa so their response is not
sufficient
we we are we're seeing some movement in
corvettes facilities
but those numbers are not good enough we
are not happy that some nations the
rich nations are already vaccinating
their 18 year olds and their 12 year
olds
whereas our working population economic
department remain unvaccinated and
therefore the economy remain closed
okay available